ja du bist jemand der das wissen wir
zumindest im studio auch ganz gerne
sieht nicht immer mit jedem per du
trocadéro
platzverweise tage da sehen sie mal herr
schäfer warum lässt du dir dass sie
nicht verbieten und warum gibt es
trotzdem ganz viele inzwischen die sagen
dass sie das sollte weg aus unserer
sprache also ich finde dass sie ist ein
geschenk der deutschen sprache an uns
alle es macht uns ja oder gibt uns die
möglichkeit dass wir menschen mit extrem
viel respekt begegnen uns auch mit
respekt begegnet werden kann dass wir
aber auch eine gewisse distanz waren
nicht leicht mit jedem bester kumpel
bester buddy sind und umgekehrt gibt es
uns dass sie wenn wir dann ins team
umschalten die möglichkeit ein extremes
vertrauensverhältnis auch durch dieses
du beispielsweise zu dokumentieren also
es hat zwei sehr wichtige komponenten
einmal die respekts und gewisser weise
auch distanz komponente und zum anderen
die freundschaftliche komponente wenn
man beispielsweise ins team wechselt und
gerade in schulen glaube ich ist respekt
extrem wichtig mögen viele anders sehen
ich halte trotzdem daran fest es bringt
nichts wenn ein schüler dem lehrer
gleichgestellt sind das ist einfach auch
entspricht nicht der realität ein lehrer
ist eine respektsperson ein lehrer muss
wissen vermitteln durch das nicht ein
vorschlag der jusos anders sagen ganz
genau die jusos in berlin haben jetzt
gefordert also man sollte jetzt
flächendeckend den lehrer dutzend und
der lehrer trotz der ohnehin die schüler
bis zum
das 18 lebensjahr also soll das
umgekehrt jetzt auch möglich sein das
ist wieder das alte klassische ding auch
bei der spd alle hierarchien weg wir
sind alle gleich wir sind alle kumpel
olaf scholz nadu kanzler also so soll es
ja quasi laufen halte ich für einen
völlig falschen weg wenig komplett ab
hier sehen wir auch noch mal das
wahlplakat von olaf schulze wurde auch
genutzt respekt für dich es zieht sich
natürlich durch
mittlerweile unseren alltag in vielerlei
hinsicht interessant dass die spd von
respekt spricht und gleichzeitig aber in
ihrem buch modus dabei bleibt denn
gerade interessant wer sie künftig sagen
könnten zu unser bundeskanzler du
absolut hat mir super musst du hast uns
ja auch ein arzt im wahlkampf habe ich
dich jetzt gewählt oder nicht wir gut
sind zurück du kannst ja hör mal auf das
und das zu machen macht das mal so
hammer hammer und aber natürlich die
rund 400.000 mitglieder der spd haben
das recht olaf scholz ohnehin zu duzen
vielleicht gibt es jetzt eine
eintrittswelle fall noch mehr menschen
olaf scholz putzen wollen wir könnten es
ja mal versuchen ich glaube er würde da
ein bisschen allergisch reagieren hat
man übrigens auch bei gerhard schröder
gemerkt als er dann die wahl gewonnen
hatte zusammen mit oskar lafontaine
plötzlich war ihm der des modus von
einem journalisten dass das fand er
überhaupt nicht mehr gut also da hat er
dann umgeschaltet aber das ist etwas da
laufen gewisse dinge wirklich schräg zu
sagen respekt und gleichzeitig ist es
hier jeden also
[Musik]